c'était la pierre angulaire du programme
du candidat benoît hamon en 2017
on y pense et oublier disparu des radars
je suis pourtant la pandémie le ramène
sur le devant de la scène le revenu
universel ou revenu de base consisterait
à verser même somme d'argent à tous les
français sans prendre en compte les
besoins ou les ressources sans aucune
contrepartie il faut dire que les
chiffres sur la précarité donne froid
dans le dos 9,3 millions de français
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté est
potentiellement un million
supplémentaire à cause de la crise liée
à la pandémie
mais le rsa ou les autres prestations me
direz vous ça existe déjà il y en a des
aides dans notre pays
eh bien oui mais en france toucher
certaines prestations sociales il est
parfois un calvaire bureaucratique entre
une montagne de paperasse et un défaut
d'information sur le sujet c'est bien
simple on estime qu'en france près d'un
tiers des personnes les plus démunies
n'ont pas recours aux aides auxquelles
ils ont légalement droit parfois
simplement parce qu'ils ne savent pas
qu'elles existent ou ne savent pas
comment y accéder
bref le revenu universel simplifierait
tout ce pataquès
reste le coût qui risque d'être salée
aujourd'hui déjà 30% du pib irait dans
les prestations sociales
alors imaginez avec le revenu universel
en finlande en tout cas l'expérience a
été tentée en 2017
deux mille chômeurs avait reçu 560 euros
chaque mois sans contrepartie cumulable
avec les allocations familiales et leurs
revenus s'ils trouver un travail
bilan deux expériences une amélioration
du bien-être mais aucun effet sur
l'emploi